>> THE 39 WINS FOR TO CARLSON.T
BACKUP HIGH FOR SCHOLZ.SEE THE
FORSLING PARED BACK UP WITH
FOR 4 BACK OUT THERE.  GIROUX.
STATE.
PENA THE
GOAL CAME JUST AS THE POWER-
PLAY ENDED.
INTHOUGH.
BLOCKED.
DEFLECTED AWAY.A ONE TIMER.   P
>> WITH THE PANTHERS
BECAUSE A BIG PL
>> THE CHIAROT REALLY
MAKE A NICE PAIR FOR THE
BOBROVSKY WITH A GLOVE SAVE
HE CARRIES.
>> HUBERDEAU , BUT
EILERS GOT IN TO THE SLOT.T TIM
TONIGHT.
>> WITH THE. HE FIGHTS THROUGH
THE CHECK BEAUTIFULLY.HOUGHT TH
BEEN ICING.
PLAY CONTINUES.
LOLO
GOES DOWN.  YOU SOLVE THE PANTH
AND NOW TO GET THEM EVEN.
IT IS CRUNCH TIME AND THAT GAME
THE LEAGUE TRYING TO DO IT
AGAIN IN LIKE THE PANTHERS,
THEY HAD